driving through the darkness in Myanmar
we're on a packed bus in a place some
call The Land of Shadows
very
early about
as our Convoy comes to a stop the
glimpse of the theatrics to come
foreign
they've been preparing for this moment
for weeks performers shipped in to show
their loyalty all for a parade
celebrating British rule 75
years ago
a chance to try and prove to the world
and its own people it's thriving
foreign
this regime seized power in a coup
nearly two years later the tanks are
rolling back in
perhaps an obvious bookend for the city
of napador a military Utopia built on
hubris
very little has been seen of Life inside
Myanmar since the coup Western
journalists rarely given any absence but
this is a moment the military want to
share and perhaps fields
for it's been accused of torture and
mass killings condemned by the UN and
sanctioned not that money looks like any
issue here
the military overthrew a democratically
elected government
[Music]
claimed the landslide victory was
electoral fraud
since taking over the Junta has locked
up and killed opponents
this is the man at the hell senior
General minang line the situation he
says is now under control and he's
promising the people a vote
is
[Music]
foreign
outside this theater there is real and
intense fighting
foreign
we wait six days to get clearance to
leave the capital this is a country well
known for jailing journalists it is
largely because of Brave local ones and
those willing to risk it all to film
that we've heard anything about life
here beyond the junta's claims
well after lengthy discussions with the
military government we've been given
permission to film elsewhere in Myanmar
it is a chance to see and hear from
people beyond the seat of power
we're on our way to began a tourist
destination they've presumably hoped
would showcase how secure and stable the
country is
the mass protests are long gone now Mass
surveillance is the talking point
[Music]
it's Majestic here
but within minutes we see a hint of the
conflict Beyond
soldiers carrying supplies crossing the
famous erawadi river where Rebellion
still rages an area we were told not to
go to
foreign
s tell us it's nothing new to these
Waters
and some are deeply anxious
we've decided to protect the identities
of everyone we've spoken to those who do
talk risk being detained and
interrogated
one that is intense fighting over there
to cross the river do you feel unsafe
yes we don't have any safety we could
die at any moment
how close are we to some of the fighting
it's not that far it's about three miles
away from here
we'll burn down the whole village the
man shouts that's allegedly the voice of
a soldier about 20 miles away
the military is accused of torching
communities
[Music]
targeting civilians in airstrikes
and labeling opponents as terrorists
the tap my door is facing a growing
armed resistance from the people's
Defense Force and ethnic armed groups
the currents of a civil war shifting
and the military doesn't control vast
swathes of the country
over there is the pukoku bridge and it
leads to the Magway region and we know
that fighting is taking place there but
we can't cross because we've been told
by the government we're not allowed to
and there are checkpoints on either side
you don't feel far from the trouble here
though and local people have told us
they can hear the clashes across the
river
however you frame the balance of power
the economy is fragile here many
desperately waiting for the arrival of
more tourists
my life has got worse since the coup
I almost lost my job my savings are gone
we all depend on the visitors for our
livelihoods what has life been like
since the coup I hear the sound of
fighting from the other side of the
river at night do you think there can be
free and fair elections here I don't
think so
they are using their weapons and their
power to threaten the people I don't
agree with them
most soaking up this sacred Sunset are
Burmese
it may be safe inside the city but with
conflict around the country Outsiders
wanting a pilgrimage to these pagodas
they need to take a leap of faith
we're on our way to Yangon when we
suddenly get a call from the military
spokesperson
who's been hard to reach and has done
very few International interviews the
military is accused of burning villages
running indiscriminate airstrikes
torture mass killings
do you have any intention of ending the
bloodshed
the machine
there will be
that Chinese
foreign
that the UN says the regime has
deliberately targeted civilians and
committed war crimes
around the mistrouded lakes of Yangon
life looks normal
[Music]
but when you look back
to where those birds fly
you see where thousands once marched
a revolution has fallen silent
many protesters fled many are in prison
the days of anti-coo tattoos are all
better raised
why do you think people wanted those
tattoos everybody was hyped up
that's why they did it
and at the time it was like they were
showing their strength what about now do
you think people would feel comfortable
having those tattoos
no when people travel overseas or
domestically they were inspected those
who travel regularly had to cover them
with additional ink
some people choose
not to travel at all
does it feel like the military is
watching everyone they spread the
information around and remind others
that if they do the same they will be in
the same trouble as a result people are
terrified
there's a pervasive sense of fear
the feeling that your every move is
being watched that can be a potent
propaganda tool
the stakes too high to share your
frustration
feel like in Myanmar right now we live
in fear and insecurity it is impossible
to protest because young peoples are
being control and arrested that's why
the youth are going toward the arm
resistance
do you feel like the Junta the security
forces are monitoring people in the
resistance simply monitor what young
people also doing online the internet is
how they control the youth
you can force a city to play ball
publicly
but you can't crush the sentiment
this is a fractured country and in
places now very violent with that
Jeopardy it's very hard to see the
military rushing to let go